the breaking news this hour the
conservative former Chancellor Nigel
Lawson has died at the age of 91 as you
can imagine tributes are coming in
um first we have is from the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak
he has tweeted one of the first things I
did as Chancellor was hang a picture of
Nigel Lawson above my desk he was a
transformational Chancellor and an
inspiration to me and many others my
thoughts are with his family and friends
at this time
or standing by is our political
correspondent Liz Bates who's at
Westminster for us and Liza sad news
this evening
yes and this is news that we've just
received in the last uh sort of 10
minutes or so we really don't have much
more information but tributes are
already pouring in you saw there from
Rishi sunak at the former prime minister
Boris Johnson has also tweeted say Nigel
Lawson was a fearless and original flame
of free market conservatism he was a tax
cutter and simplifier who helped
transform the economic landscape and
helped millions of British people
achieve their dreams he was a prophet of
brexit and a lover of Continental Europe
he was a giant my thoughts and prayers
are with his family and there are so
many tributes like that from
conservative politicians being released
on social media Greg hands is one of
those he has said that he will be
remembered for his Clarity of thinking
his commitment to free market economics
and willingness to challenge orthodoxies
James cleverly said he was a true
Statesman his contributions to this
nation will not be forgotten and there
are many more like that he was of course
a towering figure in the conservative
party in the 80s Chancellor to Margaret
Thatcher between 1983 and 89 a real
architect of the economic policy that
really changed the UK under her
Premiership he his resignation in the
end in 1989 was quite damaging to her
Premiership and where he was replaced at
that point by John Major he carried on
as an MP until 1992 after that he
entered the House of Lords and latterly
in his career he's been very much
prominent in the brexit movement he was
chair of vote leave for a long time a
real proponent of brexit and a strong
voice for brexit and as I say a real
towering figure in British politics it
was only in December last year that he
retired from the House of Lords and
obviously since that point he has been
at home we have no more information on
his death but we do know there are lots
and lots of conservative and I'm sure
there'll be MPS from across political
Spectrum paying tribute to him this
evening
Liza thank you updating us on the
reports of the death of Nigel Lawson a
former conservative Chancellor at the
age of 91 retiring from the House of
Lords only in December